we're celebrating this year 25 years of
the Dave Ramsey show being on the radio
and so we are taking pause occasionally
throughout this summer to reminisce and
talk about the old days and true to form
with that we have a huge milestone today
for the first time in 20 years ever on
the Dave Ramsey show live sitting next
to me is the producer of the Dave Ramsey
show the only one that's ever had Blake
Thompson we put him on this side of the
microphone he's never been on this side
of microphone I piped up and had
smart-aleck stuff to say from the booth
in the old days over the air but to sit
in here and actually do the show the
first time since you started twenty
something years ago welcome I'm used to
talking to you with a piece of glass
between us doesn't feel safe now does it
no it's kinda like being in the cage
with a gorilla yeah yeah it's kind of
nice on here a lot more room existence
nicer it has the meaning the seats are
so lighting is better is it as good as
you thought it was going to be extremely
nice might start my own show looks good
that's good
well welcome we've been reminiscing as I
said all all summer long we will be
every so often we're going to take a
pause and take a segment or two of the
show and just talk about the old days
and we thought it'd be fun to have Blake
actually come in here sit down and talk
about the history and like when we
started you were the first person we
were hired for the Dave Ramsey show we
had other team members at what is now
known as Ramsey solutions but the first
person or general radio was you and I
discovered if I was going to syndicate
this show if I was going to reach into
other markets with it that we were going
to need a producer at that time the show
was called the money game and it was me
and Roy Matlock doing the show and so
you get hired I was trying to remember
the other day somehow I had in my head
that we contacted somebody over at
trevecca or something and that was how
we found you is that how it happened
yeah the money game was going on in you
had a board off at the
time that was actually worked for the
station and you were reaching out to
find someone that would actually be on
your team produced the show helps
indicate on the level of production I
had yet someone calling the station's
trying to get them but at the time you
look first instead of the trades or
anywhere else in the radio industry with
trevecca Nazarene College its University
now for a possible producer and the
reason if you don't remember you called
because you had hired a sales guy
probably eight months before Steve
Roderick yeah about eight months before
and you're very pleased with him and so
you thought hey let's try Trebek again
because we had a good hire there and I
had already graduated that was 96 I'd
graduated in 93 but I had stayed in
contact with a key professor over there
in communications and I was in a men's
group or a kind of transit transition
group of guys my age that had come out
of college newly married thought they
would step right into that dream job I
had a broadcast degree and when it was
time to get married and graduate I
didn't have that just jump in and I'm
going to produce some major show or do
something like that so I had to get a
job and I was working at a copy site we
set up copy sites at these law firms
around Nashville and I'm started
managing those and you know Monday
through Friday go in there and they grew
from like a couple to twenty-something
of them and we had teams each one but I
could not stand what I was doing at the
time and I tell you I was for those
three years before I got that call it
was just like man is this what it is I
mean do I have to hate mondays all the
time and I was praying and looking for
opportunity to get in a radio side of
things and one day the worst day I think
on the job Dave two people had dropped
out and I had to cover their shift and I
was running crazy my pager goes off and
on the page or hey Jerr yeah that sells
millions in 96 the pager in the number
was at 248 it was a correct number and
long story short I called and I got
ahold of this professor and she's like
hey Dave Ramsey called back then you
have a huge team you did the work you
know you grew it hey Dave Ramsey called
have you ever heard of him and I was
like Dom no and she goes he's a host of
the show called the money game and when
she said that it's a funny thing that
we've talked about for years I remember
seeing the money game ads in the men's
bathroom at a sports bar around
Vanderbilt we used to go to called
Jonathan and I'm like I know exactly the
guy you're talking about and she goes
hey Blake this show me and my husband
listen it's changed our life it's big in
Nashville it's growing like crazy here
and he's looking to syndicate this thing
I think it's gone it's the opportunity
you've been looking for
and he's a great guy thinking you go
talk to him that's how it started Wow
and that men's group I was talking about
I just her husband worked with guys who
were like this is it and they would pray
for each other and talk to each other
hey it's coming just be ready it's going
to happen and because of that connection
it went back to her when you called and
so yeah wow those are on the corner so
you had never produced a show I didn't
even know what a producer was it
certainly didn't have know how to fill
out a job description and you come on
board and we're getting ready to start
syndicating did you have a clique look
uh yeah I just knew that but I want to
intelligence marred enough to know you
didn't have a clue yeah yeah the great
thing is is the first week I came in you
know I was still wearing the suit and
tie impress the boss kind of thing and
that's what you look like because we
talk money and all that and the first
week you and I were at wtn and we were
talking about hey we want to syndicate
this thing and we're at a table with
some bigwigs in the industry far as the
ownership of the cluster we were ends of
time and Dave was like okay we're going
to syndicate the show there's too many
people around America that aren't be in
touch we've outgrown Nashville it's time
to talk to Dallas time to talk to major
cities because these people need hope
and we're going to do that and you know
they're very busy they had bunch of
stations are running in their normal
world and you know one of them said the
engineer that had been there a long time
just said well how are you going to do
that technically and Dave looked across
the table and point
to me literally my first week on the job
and said he's going to do it and I
thought I was gonna fart chair I stayed
stoic like yeah I'm gonna do it and I
went home that night to my wife and said
hey Tanya I think Dave thinks I'm Way
smarter than I am and I know how to do
this stuff we figured it out yeah we did
we figured it out
Blake Thompson joining me for one more
segment and we're going to continue
reminiscing a little bit than our
producer of this show now the senior
executive producer and an operating
board member here at the Dave Ramsey at
Ramsey solutions but the senior producer
of anything broadcasted out broadcast
out his place nowadays and but then our
producer here for over 20 years and show
celebrating our 25th year anniversary
this year back with a little more Blake
Thompson on the Dave Ramsey show a good
friend Dave this your friend inky
johnson man I'm so grateful for your
presence on the face of this planet
honestly happy 25th thank you so much
for your heart thank you so much for
your friendship but most importantly
thank you so much for being a servant
you know and putting out knowledge
wisdom and conviction into the world
thank you so much for being there for me
personally may God bless you and
continue to be a blessing we love us
some inky johnson around here good man
didn't thinker
yeah he's a great [ __ ] great speaker
who ever get the chance to hear inky you
don't want to miss it he will light your
fire man absolutely amazing great like
Thompson joins us this half-hour as we
were celebrating throughout the summer
by periodically taking a segment or two
and just celebrating our 25th
anniversary of the Dave Ramsey show on
the air Blake was our first radio team
member came on board as the producer as
we starts indicating the show and you
know one of the things I remember you
were getting out of debt and you only
had one debt and that was on that old
Jeep and it didn't even have like air
conditioning yeah yeah we Tonya knives
first like purchased together married
was this red Jeep that we loved and we
didn't have a ton of money and we
financed it not a ton
so funny they just showed an old picture
was it not like yo if you're watching
YouTube I'm sorry
wow that's the guy I hired yeah
anyway we got this Jeep and it was a
small loan that's the only thing we had
but is still one and when I started work
with you we're like we got to pay that
thing off but as I was paying it we
would I would drive from Hermitage
Tennessee to Brentwood Tennessee which
was a pretty good haul everyday and then
okay boy 25 miles yeah and then if you
didn't know or if Dave hadn't talked
about it yet when before we built our
first studio debt-free we were using a
little small space at the Opryland Hotel
out in the front yard was a little house
at the WSM own and it was a studio and
they used it for the traffic department
and some of their offices and so Dave
and I would have not drive from
Brentwood every day to do the show and
it was a 1890 mile one way so four years
Dave and I went 40 miles round-trip just
to be able to go over and use some
equipment and use the studio of our
first station there yeah we got that for
a good two years or more from the time
you were on that's right and you came
home right before we got our very first
radio yeah I think I drove for about a
year almost a year maybe just shy of a
year eight months or so back and forth
doing that wtn and that and that Jeep
didn't have any air condition but yeah
and we drive there and then sometimes I
have to drive back to the office to do
something where we'd stay there for
production and then I just had back
terminus but the Jeep has 260 air
conditioning windows down so yeah
exactly
Oh so the first it had to be the first
month you were there we got our first
our first radio station was signed up
and we start hooking up and if I
remember right it's oak Ridge Tennessee
and Russellville Kentucky and then
Jackson Tennessee I remember the day we
came on the air with I think Oak Ridge
in Russellville must have come on the
same day all I remember is the guy from
Russellville calling you while I'm on
the air going hey guys turn it down you
got it cranked up it was over modulating
and he's we had cranked up whatever we
were sending the whatever the feed we
were sending this volume on the box yes
and he goes Dave's kind of wired up he's
like yelling into the bike and
everything because I was so excited to
have other radio stations I was bouncing
off the walls
Boise was way up there my voice volume
and everything else and of course we had
it cranked up to so I'm sure that AM
radio station we were rattling that gum
the speakers and everybody's houses with
that thing and and over modulating you
know through there all that stuff that
that was a wild time
I remember dry one of the early goals
was hey how can we make what we do in
days the principal's a household name
Dave Ramsey show what we teach etc and I
remember after we got Oak Ridge and a
few others I remember driving through
Tennessee once I'm stopping at a gas
station in Oak Ridge with a money game
sweatshirt on and someone in that that
convenience store saw it and said oh I
listen to money game in Oakridge and I
thought we had made it I mean nowadays
you go everywhere by knows who you are
but back then that was so huge that was
like the first step of hey we're
syndicated yeah I'm not we're on the
other that's inside yeah 300 miles away
somebody knew we were okay yeah but
that's exactly right yes that's pretty
cool
and the equipment has changed a little
bit yep yep man I mean the old
reel-to-reel tapes you remember those
yeah we used to edit all Dave spots and
anything we did for affiliates on
reel-to-reel and we would edit with a
razor blade and splice it nothing was
digital then and we would use tape to do
the edits and we would snail mail those
spots or those promos Dave did for the
stations and hope they were good or we'd
be going back to the trunk or doing it
again a week later when we found out
that he forgot a word or something we
didn't put in there mispronounced a word
and now these guys Dave's on a regular
schedule if you didn't know Little Pill
peel behind the curtains a little bit
the production guys have Dave on the
schedule where he's after a show a
couple times a week he'd knocks out tons
of promos tons of spots for you know 600
over 500 some affiliates and they just
shoot him right then they could even put
them Dropbox I can shoot them digitally
they can fix it right there on the fly
but that's not what we had back yeah and
I don't have to sit and because because
as a splice for the razorblade took so
much time it was easier to cut the spot
Oh
yeah yeah so if I messed up I just start
oh yeah yeah but I had ever cleane read
all the way through or we had to get the
razor blade out right and oh if you
discovered something later after I left
or something you got your in there with
your razor blade trying to make that
work and you grow those things back and
forth like a org find them find the Agra
tool under that world in the middle of
it and then and they used 8-track carts
and download the are we record from that
over onto an 8-track cart and then
that's how they ran the traffic yeah the
promos and everything else the traffic
being the commercial schedule folks or
like even like when someone yelled debt
free and we hit freedom that was on that
it was on that cart days reference and
we had recorded on this little carton
you hit it on the board and that thing
was queued up for that Braveheart screen
yeah so you just push a button and it
plays radar and like we kind of push a
button now but it's a computer playing
it but the biggest equipment change in
my opinion besides the you know the mp3
and the wav files and stuff like that
nowadays is digitally how were beamed up
on the satellite and all the affiliates
pull us down but in those early days
like with Oak Ridge we had to get this
little comm Rex box it was called and I
had to remember to literally dial up the
phone number long-distance via ISDN hook
up at the other station get on a regular
phone ask if we're connected test back
and forth every day and do that and one
day just Dave called long-distance yeah
as long differently and one of my
favorite stories is one day new on the
job at came in on a Monday Dave had me
come to his office and he was like I
need to talk to you and he proceeded to
tell me that I had forgotten to hang up
the long-distance bill the long-distance
Tom Rex on that Friday and that they had
an alert when that happens whenever your
bill exceeds a certain amount and Dave
said hey you didn't hang it up in we owe
$7000 for a phone bill over the weekend
and I I just started family I said Dave
I thought I hung it up I swear I'm not
but if but if I did and it's on me I
will do anything day I will sell
financial piece book door-to-door to pay
that bill if I have to whatever it takes
you tell me what you want because I was
so scared that I was going to have to
leave this wonderful job I just got and
then Dave he can't go long he gets the
chest landing turned red
I know that's when I knew he had set me
up as a practical joke but that's one of
the best stories still to this day I was
freaking out that was pretty brutal yeah
pretty bad yeah you you're not above
doing that to other people I've had many
of those as citizen you've been the on
the other side of that a whole bunch of
times over here that around here yeah
but I actually was John Blake's idea
okay I was working and I just I was in
on pulling it off it was brutal like he
really he was sweating that collar was
coming out those eyes were bugging
having a green thumb he'll 7,000 I said
no no you might have been as well Ben
700,000 yeah yeah knows that yes you
know absolutely out of control fun stuff
so on as we've done this all of these
years what are usually the biggest
change having been uh of course the size
of the team we were such a core little
team back then and then one of the
neatest things is like staff meetings
that you did even when I came in in 96
and we sat around a folder folded out
table or even devotionals every
Wednesday as a company we got 600 people
now and we have still done this too
today not around one table but a huge
room so I think the biggest change is
not only the size of the team and the
business units we have within this but
the cool part that didn't change is
those core things the foundation that
got us to where we are today well thank
you for walking with me for 25 years
thanks for having me and spend one it's
been the best job my life the Blake
Thompson our senior executive producer
right here on the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]